MAX SALTONSTALL: Hello.
Welcome, everyone.
My name is Max
Saltonstall and I am here
with four awesome
authors from Tor.
Can you each just introduce
yourselves briefly
and tell me a little bit
about what your book is like?
ELIZABETH BEAR: I
am Elizabeth Bear.
2015 is significant
for me because it
is my 10th year as a published
novelist and I'm still here.
Still here, still clinging on.
My newest book is
called "Karen Memory."
It is a Wild West
steampunk adventure
novel starring
heroic saloon girls
versus disaster capitalists.
And I've been describing it
as sort of like "Leverage"
if the good guys were hookers.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
That's pretty accurate.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Yeah.
JAMES CAMBIAS: So
I'm Jim Cambias.
My new book, it's my second
novel, it's called "Corsair."
And it is a near-future,
hard SF take
on a classic science-fiction
trope of space piracy.
Basically, I
figured out that you
can make space pirates
work if you leave
the pirates on the ground.
So it's a comic thriller about
Captain Black, the space pirate
and his nemesis Captain
Santiago of the Air Force.
BRIAN STAVELEY:
I'm Brian Staveley.
I write epic fantasy.
The first book, "The
Emperor's Blades,"
follows three adult children
of a murdered emperor.
There's a monk, a Special
Forces soldier who
rides on these giant
birds, and a politician,
and they're trying to figure
out who killed their father
and not get killed themselves.
Second book that's here is
"The Providence of Fire."
MAX GLADSTONE: Hi.
I'm Max Gladstone.
I write post-industrial
fantasy novels, sort of Gandalf
meets Grisham.
We have dead gods with
shareholders committees,
and wizards with
pinstripe suits,
and bankruptcy
transactions reinterpreted
as sort of necromancy
performed on
enormous semi-sentient spiritual
entities, that sort of thing.
Basically, the workaday world.
And my new book,
"Last First Snow,"
is about human sacrifice
and zoning laws.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Awesome.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Full stop.
MAX GLADSTONE: Basically.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So you've each
approached very different parts
of fantasy and Sci-Fi
and you've got,
I think, really interesting,
different settings.
How did you go
about researching,
say, your Pacific Northwest
sort of gold rush or your space
pirates?
How did you get into
that culture of it?
ELIZABETH BEAR: Well,
for the Pacific Northwest
I cheated a little bit
because I made up a city--
MAX SALTONSTALL: Rapid City?
ELIZABETH BEAR: Rapid
City, from which
I took all of the
elements that I really
liked from the
history of Portland,
San Francisco, and Seattle.
And just stuck them in a
blender, into the Vitamix,
hit whizz.
So it's got--
MAX SALTONSTALL:
With giant robots.
ELIZABETH BEAR:
It's got San Francisco's
Chinatown and Seattle's history
of the buried waterfront city.
Basically, the good bits.
The good parts version
of the Pacific Northwest
during the gold rush.
And then I read a whole bunch
about the Gold Rush and I
visited all of
those places and I--
MAX SALTONSTALL: Alaska?
ELIZABETH BEAR: No.
I haven't.
I will probably have to go
to Alaska at some point,
but not for this book.
I read a lot of
Jack London, though.
Does that count?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Sure.
That's fine.
AUDIENCE: Any relationship
to Rapid City, South Dakota?
ELIZABETH BEAR: Other
than the name, no.
JAMES CAMBIAS: So
for "Corsair," I'm
keeping it in the
relatively near future.
It only takes place in
something like 2030.
So I tried to-- it's
as contemporary-feeling
as I could get
away with and still
have space pirates, industrial
operations on the moon,
invaluable payloads of Helium3
being shipped to Earth.
So I kind of assumed that,
say, tomorrow somebody decides,
yes, that's what we'll do.
And begin setting up the
infrastructure for it.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I think
NASA actually just gave you
the announcement you
wanted yesterday.
JAMES CAMBIAS:
Well, there we go.
And I've been completely
cut off on this book tour.
I don't know.
Are we at war with Norway?
ELIZABETH BEAR: We're
on an asteroid hurtling
through the Northeast currently.
BRIAN STAVELEY: That's how
rumors get started, Jim.
MAX GLADSTONE: We've always
been at war with Norway, Jim.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Shh!
JAMES CAMBIAS: So it's
mostly the contemporary world
with people stealing spaceships.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Well,
you took some liberties
in terms of how are
things going to progress?
JAMES CAMBIAS: Well, yes I have.
since it's 15
years in the future
I had to throw in
self-driving cars
and there's a
pirate themed resort
island which doesn't really
exist, but could easily exist.
MALE SPEAKER: And should.
JAMES CAMBIAS: But
most of the rest
I tried to keep as familiar
to the reader as possible
because that's not what
the story is about.
ELIZABETH BEAR: So how about
those self-driving cars, Max?
Ha ha ha!
MAX SALTONSTALL: When your
tour takes you to Mountainview
I'm sure we'll conduct an
interview inside one of them.
BRIAN STAVELEY: I used to
teach ancient world history
and philosophy and
comparative religion,
so that was all valuable
material for the world
building.
But you know there's also a
lot of personal experience
that goes into the books.
For instance, the Special
Forces guys, the Kettral,
they do a lot of training.
And I do this sport
called adventure racing
that I've drawn on in my
conception of the Kettral.
And one of the things I would
do with my adventure racing
teammates, we had a thing
where once a week you
could call another person
on the team at 2:00 AM
and assign them a two
hour physical task
that they had to
get up and do then.
So you could call someone,
and one night I got the call.
"Get up.
You up?" "Yeah.
I'm up." "Find a 45
pound rock." "OK.
I have one in mind." "Go
carry it for two hours."
And so the Kettral have to
do a lot of things like that
and I've drawn on some
of those experiences.
JAMES CAMBIAS: This is
a sport you do for fun?
BRIAN STAVELEY: Well, that's
just the training for the sport
but it gives you a
sense of what you end up
doing in the race itself.
MAX GLADSTONE: We're using a
loose definition of fun, here.
Or an endorphin dependent
definition of fun.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Indeed.
Exactly.
Well, there is-- I don't know if
you're familiar with this term.
There's Type 2 fun.
Does this sound familiar?
Type 1 fun is fun
when you're doing it,
like drinking good wine
or having sex or whatever.
Type 2 fun is miserable
when you're doing it
but you look back on it fondly.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Like writing.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I
think we call that--
BRIAN STAVELEY: Like writing.
Writing is Type 2 fun.
And Type 3 fun is just
horrifying and never fun.
So not actually fun at all.
MAX GLADSTONE: Type
3 fun is only fun
when your grandkids are
talking about the time they--
BRIAN STAVELEY: Absolutely.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Type 3 fun is
fun when you're getting drinks
off of it 20 years later.
JAMES CAMBIAS: That's true.
Shackleton's expedition
was Type 3 fun.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Ooh.
MAX GLADSTONE: Wow.
JAMES CAMBIAS: I think
they all survived.
They all lived and went
off to fight World War I
when they got home.
MAX GLADSTONE: Goody.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Type 3 fun.
MAX GLADSTONE: Type 3 fun.
World War I?
All right.
So the research for
my books comes off
of talking to a
lot of my friends
and being an enormous nerd.
So the metaphors
that I would use,
I'd reach out for, for trying to
describe what like a bankruptcy
lawyer I was talking
to or a guy who
was working in like
nonprofit sort of organizing
fund-raising, trying to figure
out good metaphors for what
they did.
I write reached for
magic, basically.
So my wife's mother is
a bankruptcy attorney
and I grew up in, basically, the
middle of nowhere in Tennessee.
And as far as I was
concerned, bankruptcy
was what happened when the
company ran out of money,
it sold all of
its stuff and then
you use that to pay back people.
And I was talking with her
and she said, well, no.
The company's worth
something is a going concern,
so you try to figure how
to make it keep going.
And there are protections
that you put in place.
And I thought, well, OK.
So you put a magic
circle around something
and then you have this
dead body in the middle
and you carve it
open and you start
taking out stuff that's rotting
or it doesn't work quite well.
You argue with all of the
other people who are doing
this at exactly the same time.
And then when you think you
have a working body-ish thing,
you stitch it all back
together and get the lightning
generator hooked up.
And, like, Delta
airlines rises off
of the slab and shambles
forth talking about,
I don't know, increasing
shareholder value
or making flights arrive
on time or something.
MAX SALTONSTALL: And you just
summarized "Three Parts Dead."
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah.
That's "Three Parts Dead."
So that's my first book.
And I kept poking into
other aspects of this world.
So assume that
necromancy is a metaphor
for a certain kind of law.
What would other
things look like?
And by the time we get
to "Last First Snow"
we have a desert city that
bears moderate resemblance
to Los Angeles that
used to work just fine,
because they had a bunch of
relatively oppressive gods
that they worshipped who
provided water and utilities
and things like that.
But then there was a revolution
and all of those gods died.
And then you're left in a
desert city with no water
and so you need
to figure out what
you're going to do about that.
And there's some
understandable civil unrest.
So as the revolutionaries,
these sort
of immortal wizard-king
type people,
are trying to figure out how to
become water utility magnates
and fix up the city the
way they want it to go.
They run into people who liked
the city the way it was before.
And--
JAMES CAMBIAS: With
human sacrifice.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yes.
Well, yeah.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Having lived
in Las Vegas for many years,
the Las Vegas Valley
Water Authority
is the closest thing to
a god that that city has.
MAX GLADSTONE: Well
that's what I mean.
Like, more and more
of the modern world
makes sense to me
sort of exclusively
filtered through
this fantasy lens.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Don't
tell a lot of people that.
More and more of
the modern world
I can only see it through
the lens of fantasy.
AUDIENCE: Well, yeah.
I mean, certainly
don't tell the people
who are going to come
after with the white coats
that who are possibly
watching on YouTube.
ELIZABETH BEAR: They
don't watch YouTube.
MAX GLADSTONE: Well, yeah.
But I mean there's a lot of
stuff that seems like magic
to us on a day to day basis.
Right?
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Self-driving cars.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah.
Well, self-driving cars
or the smart phone,
which-- there are
very few people who
could describe how to
go from raw material to
finished smartphone,
especially if you
build in an app ecosystem and
the network communications
technology that is
required for the thing
to be even remotely useful.
People can't really go from
farm to table on one of those.
So--
BRIAN STAVELEY: I think
they're born, not built.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yes.
And that's it.
BRIAN STAVELEY: There's little
eggs that hatch smart phones.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Now
I'm picturing farm
to table smart phones.
MAX GLADSTONE: I
think Neil Stevenson
wrote a book about that.
JAMES CAMBIAS: And that's why
we had the whole phenomenon
of legal thrillers-- you
referenced John Grisham--
because increasingly,
it feels like dark magic
that no one understands, really.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Cory Doctorow
is all about the farm
to table smart phones.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah.
Right.
ELIZABETH BEAR: That's pretty
much his schtick, actually.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So
what did you take out
of your most recent book?
What did you end up pulling
to make it stronger?
ELIZABETH BEAR: What did we cut?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Yeah.
What ended up on the
editing room floor?
BRIAN STAVELEY: Just
about 60,000 words.
ELIZABETH BEAR:
I'm actually-- I'm
that weird sub-species
of write who underwrites.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Are you allowed to?
ELIZABETH BEAR: Yeah.
My early drafts
are like 15% to 20%
shorter than my finished drafts
because they're very Spartan.
They tend to be missing a lot
of things like transitions
and character motivations
and important-- things that,
it turns out, are
important to the reader.
So I have to go back and
put all that stuff in.
So I guess I'm the
opposite of Stephen King.
JAMES CAMBIAS: Well,
I have to admit
I'm kind of in the same boat.
I tend to write short.
So when I handed in the original
manuscript for "Corsair,"
my editor told me,
this is not long enough
to publish as a novel.
Please make it bigger.
MAX SALTONSTALL: It's magical.
How do you get
from the manuscript
to the novel process?
Eggs, right?
JAMES CAMBIAS: Yes.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Writer eggs.
JAMES CAMBIAS: But I was
able to-- that actually, I
think it makes it, not
just because longer,
but I think it enabled me to
add several more characters
and, I think, make the
story a bit more interwoven.
And so I'm glad that
they told me to do that.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Sort of a
building-in layers approach.
JAMES CAMBIAS: Right.
ELIZABETH BEAR: I start
off very much like Jim.
I start off very scaffoldy.
It's super pixelated.
My early drafts are
super pixelated.
And then I have to go in and
focus down, and focus down,
and focus down, and
then eventually you
have a nice, sharp, clear story.
But--
MAX GLADSTONE: Zoom and enhance.
ELIZABETH BEAR:
Zoom and enhance.
Yeah it's like CSI,
only it actually works.
MAX GLADSTONE: See, I go for
the make the block of marble
first and then chisel the
block of marble away thing.
So I write very quickly,
almost sort of on automatic,
and then I end up with
160,000 word manuscript that
becomes 105,000 word manuscript
over the process of paring it
away.
ELIZABETH BEAR: So you could
actually tell us what you cut.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah.
But the funny thing is, once I'm
done cutting I almost never am
aware of what I cut.
A lot of it is
repeated description
or you have a
conversation that's
three pages long that
becomes a conversation that's
one page long because you have
one major beat needs to be hit.
There are chapters where
I had two characters who
are going through a very long
sort of rambling set of stories
about their lives, but
then just simmered down
on the stove top to become
maybe a page and a half long.
So there are some very
short chapters in the book
because that was the one
beat that needed to be there.
And then I added in some
sort of other side plots
when they became
absolutely necessary.
I realized the book
was missing stuff
BRIAN STAVELEY: I
mean, obviously,
a big part of the job for any
of us is building the world.
And sometimes it's
not immediately
evident in the moment how much
of the world you need to build.
So in the third book that I
just finished, for instance,
there's a very tall staircase.
And to me, it was sort
of implausibly tall.
And I spent a long
time trying to figure
through the engineering
in this staircase,
and what kind of
wood are they using,
and how is it all put together.
And my wife read it
and she's like, what
is all this crap about
the stair-- it's like four
pages of staircase building.
Nobody cares about that.
AUDIENCE: Unless
you're Herman Melville.
MAX GLADSTONE: Right.
And I thought, yeah.
Nobody does care about that.
But for me, I often
need to write that stuff
and then maybe two lines
make it into the final text.
But in my head, at least, I know
how that staircase was built.
If somebody comes at me
on the next book tour,
I've got answers.
ELIZABETH BEAR: That's
the iceberg effect.
Like, 10% of your world
building is above water.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Yep.
MAX GLADSTONE: You have
the iceberg approach
or the gilding approach, right?
ELIZABETH BEAR: Yes.
Or the electroplating approach.
Tim Power's term for you
electroplate on the research,
and as long as it's flawless,
it could be one molecule thick
and nobody will ever know.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Questions?
Feel free.
AUDIENCE: Can I follow
up on a particular point?
ELIZABETH BEAR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Since you spoke
last I'll address it to you,
and also because I
read "Karen Memory"
and I enjoyed it very much.
Is that world you
had written before
or did that grow full-blown?
ELIZABETH BEAR: That
is a brand new world.
And the book was
about-- I think I
wrote the first
sentence in 2009 and it
took a long time to sell.
It was actually
very fast to write,
but it took a long time to
sell because it's weird.
It's not any other, like,
really accepted subgenres.
It's a little bit
steampunk but it's also
a little bit weird west, and
the nontraditional protagonist
and all this other stuff.
The world, itself,
was just the result
of a lot of reading and
cogitating and wandering around
in Seattle underground
and parts of San Francisco
and just trying to--
and there's a lot
of actual historic inspiration
for the characters in the book.
There's a character
in there, Mary Lee,
who's a young
Chinese-American woman who
rescues-- her schtick is that
she rescues young women who
are being sexually trafficked.
And there were people like her
in San Francisco in the 1800s.
So there's a lot of just
sort of these little bits
of American history that
have been erased or forgotten
or aren't part of the
narrative, but are so
cool that I want to talk about.
AUDIENCE: You've
already answered
the question I was
going to follow up with,
which is-- I mean, I
love when I open a book,
particularly a standalone
book, and there's a full world.
I can't imagine
the amount of work
that goes into that
that never shows.
And I was wondering
if all of you
could talk a little bit about
where your worlds come from.
JAMES CAMBIAS: Well,
"Corsair," like I said,
is mostly contemporary reality.
But my first novel,
"A Darkling Sea,"
that takes place on an alien
planet with its own native
inhabitants and involves
both the local inhabitants,
the human explorers, and
a second space-faring
civilization which is
in conflict with humans.
So I had to build two alien
civilizations, alien species,
for that.
And that was a lot of fun.
But as to the background,
to some extent
it's because we've been
interested in all this
our whole lives.
That's why we're in this job.
So the preparation for
writing "A Darkling Sea"
was, well, I minored
in astronomy in college
and I married a
biologist and I--
MAX SALTONSTALL: You cheated.
JAMES CAMBIAS: Yeah.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Preparing for
that moment all your life.
JAMES CAMBIAS: Yes, right.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Stealing
ideas from one spouse
over the breakfast table--
time honored tradition.
MAX GLADSTONE:
This is the reason
that the second book tends to
be really hard because you write
the first book and
that's your whole life up
until that moment.
And then you sit down with
another blank sheet of paper--
BRIAN STAVELEY: I
also find there's
top-down sort of world building
and bottom-up world building.
So the top-down
stuff is, you start
with a big idea about
theology or whatever,
but there is a
moment-- I'm thinking
more about my third book because
I just got done with it-- where
I had some characters in a room
and I didn't want them just
sitting in an empty room.
So I need to fill that room in.
And I put in some statuary.
And then the statuary
needs to be of something.
And I thought, well,
this character will
have statuary of these gods.
And then I need to think
of how the gods are
depicted in that statuary.
And all of a sudden you're
coming at the theology
not from, this is
my pantheon and then
here is how it works on the
people of this world, but from,
I need some crap in
the corner this room.
And suddenly the Pantheon
is growing out of that.
And hopefully those
meet in the middle.
MAX GLADSTONE: I talked
a little bit about where
my world's coming from
earlier, but there's
one particular night
that I can think of.
I had just gone to see
"Psycho" and Slavoj Zizek
was introducing it.
It was like this
weird thing that
was going on at the Brattle
Cinema in Harvard Square,
if any of you guys
have ever been there.
And I was walking back
and everything just
looked profoundly weird.
Cars were coming
by and I thought,
Jesus that's something
that's two, three tons that's
just rolling down the street
faster than a horse could run.
And I think this
is totally normal.
Like, the equivalent
of monkey-me 10,
20,000 years ago would think
this was a transcendentally
weird experience.
ELIZABETH BEAR:
That moment when you
realize that you are living
past several singularities.
MAX GLADSTONE: Right.
It's the "Naked Lunch" moment.
Right?
You see what's exactly
on the end of your fork.
And thinking about how I
could write a world that
seems that weird to
us but would also
seem close enough to something
that we-- to the world
that we live on a
day to day basis,
to highlight the weirdness of
the world that we live on a day
to day basis.
That's kind of the seed
that a lot of this stuff
is coming out of.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I need
to get across town.
Let me just grab one of
those giant dragonflies
and give it a little
bit of my soul.
And then--
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah, absolutely.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Have
my meeting on time.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Question?
AUDIENCE: So you talked
a little bit a minute
ago about bottom-up
world building.
I'm not sure who on the
group goes top-down.
I think, I'm sorry, Mr.
Gladstone if I remember that?
You were giving
this big description
from "Three Parts Dead,"
which I haven't read yet,
this really interesting,
fascinating world.
Assuming you start
there, if you do.
I don't know if this
is how you work or not.
How do you go from, here is
this wonderful, weird world,
and then find the characters
and the plot to put in it?
MAX GLADSTONE: Well, at least
the way that I was interpreting
what you were saying, is that
it all feeds into itself one way
or the other, whichever
direction you're going.
So if you have this
strong umbrella
image of what the world-- how
the world fits together, then
the next question you ask
are, what kind of people
come out of this world?
And then, what do they want?
And then, where do
they want to go?
What does their day
to day life look like?
Or if you're
starting with the day
to day life stuff then you
can blossom up from that into,
what are the major concerns
that they're dealing with?
ELIZABETH BEAR: Or
both simultaneously.
At least the way I do it,
it's very synergistic.
I've had books that started with
a sentence, with a character,
with a thematic statement, with
an argument I wanted to have,
and all of them present
their own struggles.
But the thing is, it's
like a jigsaw puzzle.
Like, you get one piece.
And then you fill
in a bit around it.
And then you find a corner
that looks like it matches.
And you put it where
you think it goes.
And then you discover, no,
actually it's over here.
And it happens on
different levels
and from different
directions simultaneously.
It's not a linear process.
I imagine there may be people
for whom it's a linear process,
but I am not them.
JAMES CAMBIAS: I like to
follow a test which is,
what stories can be told in
this setting that cannot be told
in the world in which we
are sitting right now?
So if you're postulating
a future with interstellar
travel, what
stories can you tell
that you can't tell in a setting
without interstellar travel?
And since most stories involve
somebody wanting something
or being afraid of something or
being convinced of something,
what fears or desires
or convictions
are possible in
that world, or are
impossible in that world that
would be possible in our own?
Because that's the flip side.
You can have Winston Smith
wanting to be able to sit
in his room and not
be watched in 1984,
which is a desire that
he cannot satisfy.
BRIAN STAVELEY: There's
also a just brute force
technical writing
element to it, I find.
Sometimes if I'm starting
a chapter with plot--
let's say I have a plot point
that I want to get through
and it's not working-- I'll
double back and I'll say,
let's just let
the characters go.
Let me tackle it from a
character point of view.
And if the characters
don't have anything
interesting to say maybe I'll
start with a long description
and see if that
generates anything.
And so, for me-- and I
don't know if you all
find this-- those
different approaches are
ways to get into and past some
of the roadblocks I run into.
ELIZABETH BEAR: And
even more than that,
if I'm having a hard time
writing in a particular way
I will change my process up.
Like if sitting at the
computer typing isn't working,
I will take my laptop
and go somewhere else.
Or I will take a notebook
Or I will-- I have
actually written
on little scraps
of torn up paper
because it feels insignificant.
You're just scribbling.
Right?
You're brainstorming so the
sensor part of your brain
doesn't get involved.
And I also will
sometimes go back
and reverse outline what
I've already written
to see where it's going.
MAX GLADSTONE: That is so
much smarter than what I do.
ELIZABETH BEAR: You just
sit there and bang your head
on the keyboard?
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah.
Well, just bang my head
against the story until--
BRIAN STAVELEY: You can
see this dent right here.
ELIZABETH BEAR: This is
that 10 years of experience.
MAX GLADSTONE: It's
Iron Head training.
That's what I'm
getting myself in for.
JAMES CAMBIAS: The different
physical mode is actually
something I've used, as well.
I'm a parent and any of you
who have kids know that they
need to be driven places a lot.
And when you're waiting
for something to finish,
take along a notebook and you
can just sit and write out, not
necessarily story prose, but
think on paper, so to speak.
What is this person
doing in this story
and what should he be doing?
Things like that.
BRIAN STAVELEY: My wife calls
this the crazy paper stage.
There comes a point near
the end of each book where
there's all these plot threads.
I'm trying to yoke
them together.
And that's when she
comes home someday
and I have computer paper and
post-its all over the wall.
And she just thinks, oh--
MAX GLADSTONE:
serial killer moment?
BRIAN STAVELEY: Yeah.
We're doing the crazy
papers again, huh?
It's just going to
be a week or who.
Just going to be a week or two.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Index
cards with the spray tacky
stuff on the back.
You can just stick them and--
BRIAN STAVELEY: And then
you have them on the table.
And she's like, can I just
move these for dinner?
No!
You cannot move
those for dinner.
ELIZABETH BEAR: That's why
you stick them on the walls.
Stick them on the wall.
BRIAN STAVELEY: That's
gold, right there.
MAX GLADSTONE:
Generally, the time
when I sit down to actually
do the outlining is when I've
gotten so far into the
draft that absolutely
everything looks horrible.
All the choices are
bad choices and I just
want to set it on fire.
And that's when the
reverse outlining, like,
what do I need to do to just
end this book, comes into play.
ELIZABETH BEAR: It's
also really useful
to go through and write
down everything that's
unfinished on an index card.
And then you spread
them out on the table
and you pick one up and say, OK.
This is a doable thing.
And you do that thing.
And then you put that index
card in a different pile.
MAX GLADSTONE: Getting
things done for novelists.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Yes.
This probably works for-- this
is probably good for anybody
because--
MAX SALTONSTALL: We
call it sprint planning,
but it's the same thing.
ELIZABETH BEAR: The thing
that I have been attempting
to teach myself for
the last three years
is that the little fuzzy
animal, that little mammal that
lives in my head, doesn't
like to be punished.
And if I punish it for doing
the things that I want it to do,
then it will stop
doing those things.
So what I need to do
is when it behaves
I need to give it a cookie.
And if I'm having a miserable
time and it's not working
and things are going well, I
need to get up, take a break,
wait for that moment when
the animal gets bored
and gives me an idea.
And then I give it a cookie.
And it's self-training.
You're habituating
yourself to do the thing
that you want your brain to do.
BRIAN STAVELEY:
And this explains
why you find yourself
having a beer at like,
11:30 in the morning.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Shh!
MAX SALTONSTALL: Or carrying
a rock at 2:00 in the morning.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Or that.
ELIZABETH BEAR: No,
that's punishing.
JAMES CAMBIAS: Or why there's a
little dispenser with rat chow
pellets next to your laptop.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Or cocaine.
MAX GLADSTONE: Before
I went full time,
I asked John Crowley,
what should I be aware of?
What are the risks?
And he said, well, there's
going to come a point.
You want to be very clear with
your wife about how this all
works, because there
will come a point
when she will come
back from work,
from a very hard
day at work, and she
will find you sitting on
the couch in your underwear
watching soaps and
eating jelly beans.
And she will ask you, what
the hell are you doing?
And you will say, I'm working.
And you won't be lying.
And she just needs to be
ready not to murder you, then.
JAMES CAMBIAS: I find it
impossible to picture John
Crowley sitting on
the couch, eating
jelly beans in his underwear.
MAX GLADSTONE: This was the
advice that the man gave to me.
It's not happened yet, so far.
ELIZABETH BEAR: The
third novel divorce
is an axiom in the genre.
Actual industry term of art,
"the third novel divorce."
That's the point when your
spouse realizes that this is
never going to stop happening.
MAX SALTONSTALL: It's a cycle.
ELIZABETH BEAR: It's a cycle.
Yeah, exactly.
MAX GLADSTONE: My
wife is amazing.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Do
you have a character
that you've written
that you would like
to actually spend time with?
BRIAN STAVELEY: Yes.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Which
would be your favorite?
BRIAN STAVELEY: The assassin.
MAX GLADSTONE: Oh, god.
Yeah.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Provided
I wasn't on the list.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Why?
BRIAN STAVELEY: She's
got a good sense of humor
and she likes life.
ELIZABETH BEAR: I try to
have at least one character
in every book who I wouldn't
mind being stuck in an elevator
with.
because that's what
writing a book is like.
It's like being stuck in
elevator with this person
for nine months.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I'd
love to spend time
with Connie because
it looks like she
cooks a real mean breakfast.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Yeah.
She'd be awesome.
And especially when you're
writing like a first person
narrator, you need
that person to have
that kind of-- because then if
you're writing a first person
narrator or single
point of view character
who is not somebody who your
reader wants to be stuck
in an elevator with, they're
going to go spend their beer
money on somebody else's book.
And that is not
the outcome I want.
So you're trying
to write character
who are charming and
interesting and you
want to hang around with
even if they're, maybe,
not nice people.
Like, you wouldn't necessarily
give them your checkbook
but you might take
them out to lunch
and listen to them
rant about politics.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Is there
one that stands out for you?
ELIZABETH BEAR: Karen's
actually great for that.
She's a fun character
to write because she's
one of those characters who runs
toward the sound of gunfire,
which is a great
quality in a protagonist
because then you don't
have to do any plot work.
You know, somebody screams.
She runs toward it and
the plot handles itself.
Another one I think I would
really love to hang around with
is actually the protagonist
in my first book,
Jenny Casey in "Hammered,"
who was a ranter.
And she was one of those
people who-- one of my friends
who was beta reading
the book for me
commented that she really liked
reading it because Jenny was
the sort of person who she
could imagine going out
with for a pizza, and putting
a quarter on the table,
and saying, OK.
Five minutes.
Toronto City politics.
Go.
It would just happen.
JAMES CAMBIAS: For
me, it would be
the hero of my first
novel, Broadtail,
who is a giant lobster
who lives at the bottom
of a lightless ocean
on an alien world,
and is a gentleman
and a scientist.
ELIZABETH BEAR: But
does he drink beer?
JAMES CAMBIAS: Undoubtedly,
it would be lethal.
BRIAN STAVELEY: They
have stingers, right?
JAMES CAMBIAS: Yes.
He would get stung.
Neurotoxins.
BRIAN STAVELEY: That's
the neurotoxin of choice.
Yeah.
MAX GLADSTONE: Well,
you could have a beer
and then he could have
neurotoxic stingers.
So Elayne Keverian, who
is this sort of mediator
slash necromancer--
ELIZABETH BEAR: Team Elayne!
MAX GLADSTONE: Team Elayne!
She's amazing.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I'd want
to meet her once and then
be very far away,
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah, I know.
I mean, she's the
kind of person that I
would love to have an
informational interview with.
MAX SALTONSTALL: As long as
she's not seeking you out
for an interview.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yes, exactly.
That would be problematic.
The King in Red--
who is this sort
of enormous, skeletal,
lich lord guy who's
in charge of, basically,
water and power for the City
of Dresediel Lex where
the fourth book takes
place-- he's a lot of fun
to hang around with so long
as you don't get on his bad
side and he turns you inside out
or decides to string a lyre
with your nervous system
or something.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Pay
your water bill.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah, exactly.
Pay your water bill on time.
MAX SALTONSTALL: And don't let
any demons come out of the tap.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah.
Don't let any demons
come out of the tap.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I
think the King in Red
would be an interesting
lunchtime companion.
Any other questions?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So when
you write characters
who are decidedly
unlike yourself
how do you keep the
characters true to who
you want them to be?
And where do you
draw inspiration
for those characters?
BRIAN STAVELEY: We were
talking about this a little bit
last night.
And I was saying
that this is where
I think the technical
effort of writing
coincides with the
moral effort of living.
In that, when I
was in high school
I would go to these parties
and be like, she's an asshole
and I don't want to talk to him.
And that was bad living, right?
But it's also
crippling for a writer
because you don't get those
characters into your head.
And as I got older,
and even more and more
this is an ongoing
process, I find
people, all kinds of people,
more and more interesting.
And that leads to a better
life which is really nice.
But it also makes it
a hell of a lot easier
to write the
characters in books.
JAMES CAMBIAS: Yes.
The characters may be externally
different from yourself,
but in order to be able
to write them at all,
really, you have to find that
zone in your head somewhere
which can be mapped on to them.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Well, but
sometimes writing somebody
who's very culturally
different from myself,
for whatever reason--
what I try to do
is go out and read
a lot of fiction
by people who fit into that
demographic because reading
books about 19th
century China is
very different from
reading a bunch of books--
even in translation which is
all I can manage because I'm
an American and I speak one
language fluently and two
very badly.
Read primary texts or as
close to the primary text
as you can get.
And in that way, kind
of try to internalize
the cultural values.
And this is just as relevant
in 21st century America.
America's a big country.
There are a lot of
people in it with a lot
of different
backgrounds and a lot
of different social and
cultural expectations.
And I have to-- I'm a
43-year-old white female
Yankee, and those
are all things I
need to be aware of when
I am writing somebody
who is not those things.
Even if it's a
generational difference,
that their expectations are
going to be very different.
MAX GLADSTONE: So two sort
of approaches that I use.
One is very close to what
you guys are talking about.
The more intense your
self-image, the more you're
like, I am this kind of person.
I do these things.
I do not do these things.
The harder it is
to write characters
who are unlike yourself.
So the more you can break open
that and find parts of you that
may be in internal
contradiction or conversation,
that's where some of the
really cool characters
are going to come out of.
Then, of course, like,
epical research in order
to be able to capture
people who are not like you.
The other thing, this
is sort of dumb trick,
but there are
situations in which
commonalities of human
experience come out a lot more.
As someone who really likes
writing thriller plots,
where there's a lot of,
like, what's going on?
Oh my god, we're being
attacked by giant whatevers.
Like, let's run.
The bomb's about to go off.
Whenever you get people down
on to the most basic hierarchy
of needs levels, it's easier
to write, authentically,
folks who are very
different from you
and very different
from one another.
And if you can get your
characters on that level,
then sometimes, if you
have done enough research
and if you've done enough
of the spiritual work
that Brian's talking about--
BRIAN STAVELEY: I don't know
if it's spiritual, but--
MAX GLADSTONE: It
is spiritual, I
mean, for whatever
definition of spirit
you want to be working on.
Right?
Then you can progress from that
up towards the sort of higher
levels and figure out how
the character would differ
from you or anyone else in more
staid or less immediately life
threatening situations.
ELIZABETH BEAR:
But also the thing
that James is talking
about plays into that.
That looking at the
parts of yourself
that are not the
things that are part
of your immediate identity.
You know, like I am
this kind of a person.
Well, yes.
I may think I'm this
kind of a person,
but there's a lot of conflicting
stuff going on in my head.
And there are urges and
rationalities and logics
that do not-- the little guy who
thinks he's driving the machine
is not necessarily
cognizant of and would not
want to acknowledge.
MAX GLADSTONE: I think we can
make that sort of Whitman's
step, right?
If you can be large
and contain multitudes,
then it gets easier.
ELIZABETH BEAR: And
study anthropology.
I mean, that's the other thing
because the entire purpose
of an undergraduate
anthropology degree
is to alienate you from your
own culture and the rest
of humanity so that everybody
looks like an alien, including
yourself.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Also
the lobster people.
ELIZABETH BEAR: No, the
lobster people are like--
JAMES CAMBIAS: Also,
read old books.
Read books written
in different times
as well, because
that way-- the world
of the 19th century or the
18th century is not our world.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
What have you read
that's really changed
how you thought
about fiction or about writing?
JAMES CAMBIAS: What
have I read that changed
how I thought about fiction?
BRIAN STAVELEY: I suspect
the answer for all of us
is tons of stuff.
Right?
If you ever get
to a point where,
even for a year
or six months, you
have the same idea about
fiction or writing,
that's probably
kind of a bad sign.
Right?
And so you stumbled
from crisis to crisis
where you read--
I just read David
Mitchell for the first
time, for instance.
And I thought, oh, no.
There's all these other
things I haven't even
been thinking about.
But that's just the
latest example of that.
And hopefully, if you're
reading good stuff,
every writer provokes a kind
of mild crisis where you think,
I wasn't doing that.
MAX GLADSTONE: How can I?
BRIAN STAVELEY: And I
think the moment where
you start thinking, yeah I'm
on top of this, that's probably
a very bad point to be.
ELIZABETH BEAR: My
agent claims that there
are no words that
strike more terror
into her heart
than author saying,
I really like this book.
I think this is
going to do well.
MAX GLADSTONE: And it's
funny because people
think that it's the ideas
that one gets jealous of
or that one wants to
hoard, but it's techniques.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Ideas
are a dime a dozen.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Oh, yeah.
MAX GLADSTONE: How did you
manage to make me cry there?
How did that happen?
JAMES CAMBIAS: I am going
to make one recommendation,
though, and it's an odd one.
It's a short story
collection by Roger Zelazny.
ELIZABETH BEAR: I was
going to bring up Zelazny.
JAMES CAMBIAS: "Frost and
Fire" I think it's called.
And he has wonderful
story introductions
and afterwards to
each piece in that.
And taken together, they
are an excellent guide
to how to be a fantasy and
science fiction writer.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Let's all
talk about Roger Zelazny.
MAX GLADSTONE: Let's.
JAMES CAMBIAS: There
are worse things.
MAX GLADSTONE: Y'all should
be reading Roger Zelazny.
ELIZABETH BEAR:
There's this thing.
I remember precisely
the two things
that made me understand how
unreliable narrators worked.
And one of them was the
Rick Springfield song
"Jessie's Girl."
Where like, the 357th time
this thing comes on the radio
you're like, ohhh!
Because the song knows
why this guy can't get
laid even though he's
a first person narrator
and he doesn't know.
But the song is
presenting a portrait
of this absolutely
reprehensible human being who
is totally not self-aware.
And the other one was,
I was halfway through--
it was like the third or fourth
time I had read the Roger
Zelazny's Amber novels-- and I
was like halfway through "The
Guns of Avalon"-- and I remember
I was standing in the shower,
both hands in my hair, getting
the Prell in there, and I went,
that son of a bitch
is lying to me.
It clicked.
And in my defense, I was
probably 14 years old.
It just clicked that the
narrator was actually
lying to me, and that was
why things in the story
didn't match up.
Like his version of
events didn't match up
with what other characters
in the story were saying.
And it was epiphany.
You know the mind blown .gif?
It was like that except
with more shampoo.
MAX GLADSTONE: Zelazny was one
of the early ones for me, too.
His book "Lord of
Light," actually.
This is a novel of
layers and layers
and layers and
layers and layers.
ELIZABETH BEAR: An
epiphany in every book.
MAX GLADSTONE: Right.
You have-- spoiler alert.
There's been a colony
ship that's crashed
on a distant world.
And several hundred,
possibly 1,000 years later,
the descendants of the colonists
have set up this civilization
that's based off of the culture
that they were coming out of,
which is sort of
Indian sub-continental.
And the crew members had figured
out body to body transmission
and cloning and have
set themselves up
as gods, many of them
from the Hindu pantheon.
And the book is written
almost in-universe.
So the language is that of
a kind of prose translation
of the Mombarta,
but the experience,
like what's actually
going on underneath,
is pretty well thought-through
science fiction.
And the characters who are
operating in the milieu
are aware of both aspects.
So there's one guy,
Sam, the main character,
wants to start a revolution
against these people who
have set themselves up as gods.
So he thinks, well, I'm
going to "invent" Buddhism
in this context, and go
about being the Buddha.
And so on the one
hand is this narrative
of the construction of Buddhism
and on the other hand's
like a sort of scientific,
science fictional sort
of political ploy.
And the open question of,
is this a fantasy novel?
Is this guy really the Buddha?
What does being
really the Buddha
entail in this
sort of a scenario?
Is this science fiction?
Like, every single
layer gets activated.
And the more I read it, the
more sort of parts of an onion
I peel back.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Matryoshka
doll after Matryoshka doll.
It just keeps unpacking.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah.
And the notion that you
can do so many things
in one book, which is smaller
than, I think, most novels that
get published today.
It's very slim.
ELIZABETH BEAR: They
would send it back to Jim
and tell him to write
another 20 chapters.
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah, exactly.
BRIAN STAVELEY: But
then what I find happens
is you get obsessed with
something like that.
You've read this book and
you think, I need to do that.
And you spend a year doing
that and then next year there's
the next thing that comes along.
You're like now I
want to do that.
ELIZABETH BEAR: And the
thing is that you're
really bad at this thing that
you really, desperately want
to do.
And you screw it up,
and you screw it up,
and you screw it up, and
you finally go, oh, I'm
never going to figure this out.
And you go on to screw
up the next thing
and discover that you're
doing the thing you couldn't
do when you were
actually trying to do it.
Am I the only person
that's happened to?
MAX GLADSTONE: No, no, no.
Yeah, absolutely.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Other questions?
AUDIENCE: What did y'all do
before you became full time
writers, and what was
that transition like?
BRIAN STAVELEY: High school
teacher, and terrifying.
ELIZABETH BEAR: I had a series
of stereotypically crappy
artist jobs.
I was an office manager.
I was a stable hand.
I did microbiology
procedure manuals
at Hartford Hospital, which
was actually a great job.
I loved my boss.
I wrote news summaries
for a clipping service,
a job I refer to to this
day as the media mines.
Think the spice mines of Kessel,
except watching Dateline.
Actually, the reason I went full
time was because I was living
in Las Vegas at that point in
time and the tourist economy
crashed after 9/11.
And I lost my job.
So there was nothing else to do.
It was like I got pushed.
It was a baby bird scenario.
I did not, like, make a
conscious decision to,
I'm going to go
write full time now.
It's like the job with
the safety net went away.
JAMES CAMBIAS: I kind of took
it sideways in many ways.
I had a couple of
jobs in publishing
but then I moved with
my wife to a place
where there were
no publishing jobs.
And so I decided,
well, this will
be a good opportunity for
me to try freelance writing.
But I was doing it for
role playing games.
I was writing source
books for various role
playing game publishers.
And back then,
every game publisher
had a house magazine
with adventures
and supplemental material in it.
And I could write a 3,000 word
role playing game magazine
article a week.
So the main problem was finding
enough outlets for my output.
And also doing some
freelance nonfiction writing.
And it was only
after I had begun
to sell some short
stories that I
decided to make the
transition to writing fiction.
MAX GLADSTONE: I was teaching
in China for a couple years
and writing books on the side.
And came back in 2008
just as the US economy
did the Anakin Skywalker
face plant into the lava.
ELIZABETH BEAR: It's
amazing how often
the economy doing a
face plant into the lava
figures in these
stories somewhere.
MAX GLADSTONE: Which was sort
of the prompt for writing "Three
Parts Dead," because you know,
bankruptcy and lawyers sort
of flying off to try
to save the country
was a lived experience
of a lot of people
that I knew at that time.
And in 2009 I had a
job working for a sort
of white paper marketing
firm in the Boston area.
And that was going
on for a few years
as I was trying to sell the
books, writing more books.
And then one of them
sold just as my wife
was getting a good job.
And it was like, grab the brass
ring while it's coming around.
See what happens.
And I've been hanging onto
the brass ring ever since.
MAX SALTONSTALL: There's
another question.
AUDIENCE: In that regard,
since you brought it up,
in this day and age, how
do you go about-- you have
your first completed novel.
At least the first one
you're happy about.
How you go about selling it?
Do you publish it
online these days?
Do you go the E. L. James route?
Do you shop it around?
Even then, what do you
after you-- like you said,
you printed your first one
and then you have more.
And then how do you keep going
if you don't have-- especially
if they're not within the genre
confines of sci-fi or something
else?
MAX GLADSTONE: To answer
the second question first,
as soon as you finish a book,
at least in my experience,
the next book is kind of
waiting there to get going.
And the process
of selling a novel
is a long and complicated one
with many paths and byways
and tangles and turns.
So the only thing to
keep me sane, anyway,
was to start on the next book.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Finish
the submission draft
of whatever book it is.
And if you're going the agented,
traditional publishing route,
you start trying
to find an agent
with a series of queries and
query letters and submissions.
And meanwhile you're
writing the next book.
When I broke in, I had
written three novels
that had been rejected
by various agents
before the fourth novel
that I had written
was picked up by an agent.
And by the time she
sold it, I was actually
halfway through the third book
the trilogy which worked out
really well for me
because I got a three book
deal for my initial contract
rather than a two book deal,
which contributes to buzz.
Because anytime anything a
little out of the ordinary
happens, the publishing
industry goes, oh, you know,
this person got a special deal.
They must be--
and really, it was
just that I could deliver
two manuscripts immediately.
Shh!
Oh, sorry.
JAMES CAMBIAS: Yeah.
I'm kind of facing
that hurdle right now.
I wrote "Corsair" mostly
before "Darkling Sea" came out
but I'm still finishing the
next book even though "Corsair"
is already on the shelves.
So I'm struggling to
catch up, basically.
MAX SALTONSTALL: How'd
you get published?
BRIAN STAVELEY: Why is
everyone looking at me?
MAX GLADSTONE: You
haven't spoken yet.
BRIAN STAVELEY: I came at
it from totally left field.
And I didn't know anything.
And I was stupid.
And so I thought, well, "Game of
Thrones" is like 300,000 words,
so I'll write something
that's about 300,000 words.
My editor is sitting here just
cradling his head in his hands.
That seems like a
good way to start.
And it was not.
Don't do that, by the way.
No agent will look at some
random person they've never
heard of and think,
oh 300,000 words,
that's a great
length for a book.
MAX GLADSTONE: They'll
look at it and laugh.
get a good belly
chuckle out of it.
BRIAN STAVELEY:
Yeah, that's right.
And then never respond to you.
ELIZABETH BEAR: It's a
nice length for a trilogy.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Well, yeah.
But eventually I found an agent.
And then the agent
does the negotiation
with various publishers.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ELIZABETH BEAR: I mean, I've
done some self-publishing,
but it was all after
tread publishing for me.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MAX SALTONSTALL: One
more question back there.
AUDIENCE: How do you go
from an idea to like.
committing to that
idea, meaning like,
I'm going to create an entire
novel around this idea.
And how many ideas
do you cycle through
before you committed to one?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Or how
do you fail faster so you
can discard the bad ones?
JAMES CAMBIAS: That's actually,
yes, a damn good question.
ELIZABETH BEAR: It is.
JAMES CAMBIAS: For
the first one it was,
that was the idea
I had at the time
which seemed like I could
make a novel out of.
But the next one,
actually for "Corsair,"
I followed sort of an
interesting approach
which I had heard about
from Mary Robinette Kowal.
Which is, she kind
of draws up a list
of novels she's like to
write and then asks her agent
which one they could sell.
And that's sort of what
we did with "Corsair."
This is a book
that I could write
and my agent
thought it would be,
of the ones I had suggested, was
the one that was most sellable.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Once
you're established
you get a fair amount of
input from editors and agents
as to what they might
like to see next.
When I'm just
starting out or when
I'm writing something that's
just for me, like short fiction
that I'm going to then write
and sell as a completed piece
to a magazine, which involves
a submission and rejection
process, still, to this
day, I still get rejections.
The way that works
is basically, when
I have an idea I start
a file for the story.
If it has a title,
I give it a title.
I save it in a
file with the date.
And every time I
work on a story,
I save it in a new
file with a new date
because that's how my
backup system works.
That way I have iterating--
if one file gets
corrupted I have everything
on either side of it.
And then basically, I just
wait until-- unless I've
got a deadline pushing
me, I wait until the idea
becomes compelling.
And then I write it.
And the thing is that
ideas never go away.
I've got one short
story which rejoices
in the title of "On Safari
in Ralay and Carcosa with Gun
and Camera," that has
consisted of that title
and a first sentence since 1989.
And now I've got like
a paragraph and a half.
And this sucker's
going down before 2020.
That's my commitment.
And I know it's going to be
like a 5,000 word short story.
It's just taken me forever
to get my teeth into it.
JAMES CAMBIAS: I've
had a similar one.
I'm not going to
spill the title,
but I've got a
short story which I
keep coming back to every year.
And it's like, can I
write this one yet?
No, as it turns out.
BRIAN STAVELEY: I
also think writing
a book is a little bit like
mountaineering or marriage.
Right?
You know, if you
have a peak in mind,
you don't know what the
weather is going to do.
All you can do-- you
check the forecast.
You check the conditions.
You're as sure as you can be
that you can do that that day.
And then you get to a point
where you just go for it.
And same way with marriage.
You can't be certain what's
going to happen in 20 years,
but you know you
love that person.
And you're as sure
as you can be.
And then you go for it.
And I feel the same way
with writing a book.
OK.
I think I can do this.
And I love it.
ELIZABETH BEAR: And a book
is a shorter commitment
than a marriage.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Yes.
Yes.
And less deadly
than mountaineering.
ELIZABETH BEAR: Yes.
And hopefully a longer
commitment than a mountain.
BRIAN STAVELEY: Yeah.
And less deadly.
MAX GLADSTONE: So less nomic,
but honestly, I have a--
BRIAN STAVELEY: I
didn't even [INAUDIBLE].
MAX GLADSTONE: Yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
That's good.
I have a notepad on my phone,
like one little note document,
and if I come up with an idea
for a book, I'll write it down.
And I generally have a
couple of projects on deck.
And this was true before I
ever got a publishing deal.
I had the book that I was
working on at the moment
that I kept chipping away on.
You really need to
finish something
if you're going to ever have a
hope of getting it out there,
or even just showing
to your friends.
Be like, hey!
Check it out!
Look, I did it!
Read it.
It's great.
And then you watch them
while they're reading it.
What do you think?
ELIZABETH BEAR: That's
a little creepy, Max.
MAX GLADSTONE: Well, you know I
never claimed not to be creepy,
ELIZABETH BEAR: Fair enough.
MAX GLADSTONE: But
anyway, so-- so that's
like a nine month
process for me.
It's slower for some people
and faster for others.
And that means a lot
of ideas just pile up.
And they just go in the notepad.
And I almost never
look at the notepad.
The question is which of those
ideas that I actually committed
to virtual paper, anyway,
stay alive in the mind
until I'm sitting
down and I'm staring
at "The end" on the
second or third book
that I had plans to write.
And then it's like, well,
what am I-- oh, that one.
That one.
They just live.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Thank you
all very much for coming.
We've got some
books in the back.
And stick around,
maybe, for a couple
of minutes to do a little
bit of signing and chatting?
MAX GLADSTONE: Thank
you for having us.
Thanks, everybody.